[Music]
U.S President Joe Biden rolled out the
red carpet for his first official state
visitor French president Emmanuel macron
and macron it's a visit designed to
highlight France's historic position as
America's oldest Ally an alliance with
renewed importance says McCraw with war
once again on European soil and what is
at stake in Ukraine is not just
very far from here
in a small country somewhere in Europe
but it's about our values Biden says
he's willing to hold direct talks with
Russian President Vladimir Putin if he
decides to end his invasion of Ukraine
I'm prepared if he's willing to talk
to find out what he's willing to do but
I'll only do in consultation with my
NATO allies I'm not going to do it on my
own on this foreign policy issue the
pair is aligned in its condemnation of
the Russian invasion but there are
differences when it comes to Biden's
domestic policy known as the inflation
reduction act KRON believes its
subsidies benefiting American companies
could ignite a trade War there's tweaks
that we can make that can fundamentally
make it easier for European countries to
participate and or be on their own but
that is something that is a matter to be
worked out there is no fundamental it
was never intended when I wrote the
legislation I never intended to exclude
folks who were cooperating with us the
Riff follows last year's uproar over
Australia canceling a deal to buy French
nuclear submarines to buy U.S Subs
instead but in China the two men are
again somewhat apart both are concerned
about China's assertiveness in the
indo-pacific but France hopes to make
China a partner not a competitor unlike
the United States
still the White House insists those
differences are being resolved and
moving forward the pair vows to
cooperate on a range of issues and
synchronize their actions Kimberly
helken Al Jazeera the White House